the Joe Rogan experience have you looked
into any of the connections between
ancient religions and psychedelics like
any of the gianmarco allegro stuff yeah
I did I didn't go that deep into it I
went in deep enough to know that there
are a lot of very serious scholars and
and he Allegro is one and Carl ruck is
another and Gordon Wasson the guy who
kind of brought psilocybin to the West
who I write about at some length in the
book really believed that it was
experience of psychedelics which has
been in culture for thousands of years
and we know whether you're talking about
the Amazon or Africa or and that these
experiences may have nurtured the
religious impulse you know where do you
get the idea of a beyond where do you
get the idea of a heaven or a hell if
not from some altered state of
consciousness
you know people talked about visiting
the underworld in homers time so how did
they do that was it dreams dreams don't
have the authority that psychedelic
experience has there's something about
psychedelic experience that that has
this it's not just an opinion it's just
not it's not a fantasy it's something
real it's objective truth this is
William James called the the noetic
quality of the mystical experience and
that certitude comes from psychedelics
and and so it seems totally plausible to
me that at the very earliest stages of
humanity if if people were indeed taking
psychedelics this might explain how they
came up with these ideas there are other
alternative theories and it's not
provable I just don't know how we would
begin to prove it but it seems plausible
and you know the ancient Greeks had a
psychedelic that they used we think
called it they called it the kikiyaon
KY Keo an and they had an annual ritual
ceremony and it was the only time in the
year where you could use this drug and
it was a ritual to infer Demeter and
harvest or planting time and everybody
in Greek society did this and people
it was secret it was called the
mysteries the Eleusinian mysteries and
you weren't supposed to talk about it
but there's a few accounts around and
people talked about visiting the
underworld making contact with the dead
and Carl ruck who's a classes has to be
you says well that was a that was a
psychedelic potion we don't know what
they were using whether it was mushrooms
or something else the the Greek use of
drugs is very obscure they only talked
about wine but the way they describe
what wine did to you there was clearly
something added to it that they were
adding other plant drugs to their wine
because they would have these tiny
little glasses and they'd take these big
trips so we don't know what it was yeah
tiny glasses and they were very careful
about when you used it and and you know
people would completely lose control and
it was just like no this isn't wine this
is something else
yeah it is some sort of a psychedelic
from grapes or no - well I mean we don't
know some people Albert Hofmann who
discovered LSD or invented LSD he
thought it was air got that they figured
out a way air got is it is a fungus that
grows on green and it was the the
precursor chemical to LSD comes from our
God and our God is responsible for
episodes of mass delirium in European
history you get a really wet year the
air got grows on the Rye people eat
bread made from it and they go crazy
some people think the Salem witch trials
was came after a wet year and people had
absorbed these women had eaten ere
gotten were having visions and things
like that which was interpreted as
witchcraft which to them was a very I
thought they were saying that the men
had absorbed it and thought they were
under spells oh maybe maybe that maybe
that - I just did probably everybody's
trip on yeah so anyway so so they think
thinking is if you just eat air got
you're not going to be you could get
gangrene it's it's a myth it's not a
clean chemical and but the thinking of
Gordon Watson and Karl Rock and they
were collaborators on this theory was
that the Greeks perhaps had figured out
a way to derive a pure chemical from our
God that could be made into something
very much like LSD
but again nobody has succeeded and
they've tried for the last 20 or 30
years to take air got and make something
you know through simple processes that
the Greeks could have mastered so it may
have been a mushroom you know there's a
lot of psychedelic plants out there it's
one of the mysteries of evolution that
you know DMT is like coursing through
the plant world yeah yeah yeah so so I I
do find it plausible that there's some
links between psychedelics I think
psychedelics have have influenced
cultural history at various points along
the way and one of those may have been
to kind of nurture this religious
impulse but again